hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cyber
and we're gonna watch another trailer
for the evil within have you seen any of
the trailers not a whole lot Alex saw
one and people were like there's so many
other ones out there that really show
the game even more there's a ton I do
want to watch this you know what enough
talking damn man you were saying all the
words I said Georgia shut the [ __ ] up
for one minute and let's just watch this
goddamn trailer I should bitch-slap you
saw I would love that I would get so
shout case this is from 2013
this games come take forever to come out
yeah this is an old one yeah I know like
this games taking forever to come out
yeah I'm yet to watch this trailer so
let's do this okay
I understands that how are you 13 this
is Sebastian Castellanos what's
happening up there oh man look at that's
dope
that's never what you want to hear
she's cute
what the hell is everyone there are no
weapons left in their cars there's no
one here to report in smell yeah smells
like blood
I'd stay sharp it's the police and study
their spirits oh whoa oh oh no thank you
Oh
oh geez Oh something it's the thing nice
that game likes unemployed that's okay
looks really cool I like the setup of
the character a lot - it goes beyond
gameplay you know like when you play
Metal Gear Solid you love playing
assault snake when you play Uncharted
you love plane is ready Nathan Drake did
ya bring home yes you got it for a
second in this one I'm like I'm looking
forward a plane as this bad ass
detective man that looks really cool it
looks like a mix of outlast in Resident
Evil yeah it definitely does have the
resident evil by for sure yeah I'm so
good with that and it looks terrifying
looks like a terrifying experience
revealing a little ploy you magic this
game is in 3d 3 if there is a potential
there's the potential I mean as far as
like gaming in 3d things unless you have
a 3ds that kind of gimmick came in with
pretty for yes is er yeah but others
another one out guys there's another one
out mm-hmm I think we should watch that
one too Dan okay okay good good this is
called transitioned or transitioning
leave a nice segue exactly segue into
the next one next video open new
contents
does have that like classic horror vibe
to it
Oh
all this seems okay
no face puppet
oh sure there's something wrong with
this place
ah fast doctor Jesus
am I going crazy you be a little bit
with yourself knowing where I'm gonna
make you too
sigh
I'm loving this game already I'm loving
the way it feels like it does feel like
haunting us [ __ ] it does remind me a lot
of like old-school horror but with
modern day twists in it [ __ ] is going on
in this game I don't know I can't even
piece it together anymore like the first
one I was like okay and this one I'm
just I can't
what's happening what I like about it
too is that it seems like there's
probably gonna be some cool mysterious
story behind it like something where
when in a bulge you're like this could
be a movie I just hope it's not overly
complicated as he's like I hope so yeah
it just looks like it's gonna just Eskil
it into more mortgages ready yeah
just more like what the [ __ ] is going on
well anyway guys thanks for telling us
to watch that trailer or the gameplay
trailers once you subscribe to the real
rejects if you want to if you feel like
it there's no pressure no pressure but
if you don't do it um you're kind of an
[ __ ] just thank Lita subscribed dance
channel oh yeah check it out he has a
gaming channel does gameplays and stuff
yeah there's good stuff on there too
it's it's fun it's a fun vibe more
family-friendly than this channel with
all the [ __ ] and shits that you could
share with your friends and family yeah
sorry I'm just kinda I'm trying to tame
us down because Dan and I got our first
rejected video for content being
inappropriate so I'm trying to make sure
we you know I honestly have no idea what
yeah the Elven we said it was for a Halo
trailer and I'm really hoping that we
did not cross the line this time I don't
know what we did I don't know what we I
don't remember it being that bad I look
here's I'm going to say on this channel
okay I've talked about getting a [ __ ]
while being high yeah
you've seen my pubic hair yep you see my
ass hit a girl my dick apparently I said
something I'm assuming it was me it
would be okay Ross the line this time I
say word
that hurt extra line that's right is
tapering forwards net so it's on you man
not me
hey ton [ __ ] let's do something shouting
out to some homeless Darrin Mortimer hey
Ryan can I get a shout out please
I'm a big fan and I live in the Bahamas
dude Bahamas are cool man
could we come hang out dude that'd be
cool Darrin Darrin like Darren Aronofsky
who [ __ ] not Natalie Portman who did
you sleep with I have no idea I thought
it was someone famous
anyway Darrin I'm gonna assume that
since Darren Aronofsky's not having sex
with someone famous that you yourself
are having sex with someone who is not
famous which is a letdown can't just be
excited for a bro be havin sex like III
there's a girl I had sex with and she
will be famous one day okay
mm-hmm you guys want a home talking
about do you want to get slapped in the
face I think I think it'll be a lot
worse because I think you might get
stabbed I think I might uh I think you
might need to bail right now and restart
the shop anyway enjoy the Bahamas Darrin
I want to come hang out it's great there
so I say feel like solace are giving you
like four shout outs because you can
keep not catching my shout outs but just
gonna put that out the real fast
Robbie stables hi you said dude you have
to shout me out cuz now I know we go to
all the same porn sites yes man let's do
some promotion here Dan I'm trying to
get you know some sponsoring here
youporn calm fantastic really represents
Brassard HD really well pornhub calm
that's where I discovered asset Kiera
fantastic asian porn actress probably
one of the hottest porn actresses ever
and then there's red tube which is
awesome ex videos all the ex videos
tends to contain some videos that really
cross the line like there's like incest
stuff there's you know [ __ ] on
people's stuff you know making people
vomit like there's crazy stuff on there
it's fun to watch with your friends and
but it you know like you won't want to
jerk off to it unless you're into that
and then you're into that what else is
there Dan to bait is good and you wonder
why have so much goddamn bad we're
[ __ ] computer I hope we don't get a
content
appropriate flag too late it's too late
I already did it anyway Robbie we did it
man we promoted the foreign sites
together thank you thank you it's nice
to know someone out there jerks off to
the same side side sure Tyler pew sec
hey found your channel when you did the
walkie dead trailer reaction video
I've been Captain Hook since reviews are
fun to watch you add freaking awesome
humor to it all Lovitz would appreciate
a shout-out to you bro Tyler that is a
great shout out to end this video Han
because it reminds me just how
incredibly awesome I truly am
I am like the coolest guy I know and and
what and Jerry Jerry is also awesome and
Jeremy Jeremy is the [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] one for me who you think
I'm gonna say your name dad come on
you're an [ __ ] in real life they're
gonna make a sequel to Dan in real life
and it's gonna be called Dan's an
[ __ ] in the real life really gets
reface on them I thought the most
[ __ ] hilarious all right Tyler thanks
for watching
forgot about that River you're awesome
thank you